mais d'abord la première étape d'une
séquence internationale pour emmanuel
macron bruxelles avec cette question le
président français est il affaibli par
le résultat des législatives mathias
arese c'est un emmanuel macron
fragilisés au niveau national qui est
arrivé ce jeudi au sommet européen le
président français adeptes du
dépassement politique tant apprécié à
bruxelles mais sans capacité de
gouverner son pays pourrait être au
coeur des discussions de couloir il
n'est pas effectivement dans une
position favorable lorsqu'un président
et chef d'état ou un chef de
gouvernement se rend à une réunion
internationale dont on sait qu'il n'est
plus soutenu par sa majorité politique
donc c'est de nature en effet à
l'affaiblir contrairement à la plupart
de ses homologues emmanuel macron
impoliment fuit les micros lors de son
allocution mercredi il avait appelé les
oppositions à clarifier leur posture
avant son retour prévu vendredi une
demande perçue comme un ultimatum
il n'y a ni ultimatum ni question de 48
heures j'ai réécouté avec beaucoup de
précision les propos du président de la
république qui a parlé ces mots sont
précis à son retour du conseil européen
dont on parle c'est twitter demain à son
retour du conseil européen effectivement
dans 48 heures demain soir nous
commencerons à bâtir c'est à dire que
c'est tout sauf un ultimatum un
ultimatum c'est la fin là ils ou
en belgique le chef de l'état entame une
séquence diplomatique qui le tiendra
éloigné de la france jusqu'à la fin du
mois il se rendra dimanche en allemagne
pour le g7 puis à madrid au sommet de
l'otan cette séquence internationale du
président mais beaucoup d'autres thèmes
d'actualité évidemment d'actualité
politique a abordé avec mes invités tout
de suite avec sa germond bonsoir
bienvenue vous avocate et présidente du
cercle de réflexion france audacieuse
saab et louise anne bonjour vous êtes
journaliste politique au monde en charge
du suivi de la droite jean louis missika
bonjour bienvenue responsable éditorial
du cercle de réflexion terra nova
hauteur avec henri verdier de ce livre
le business de la haine internet la
démocratie et les réseaux sociaux publié
aux éditions calmann-lévy laetitia culpa
éditorialiste politique bonsoir
bienvenue laetitia à mes côtés comme
chaque jeudi et chaque mardi
question toute simple pour démarrer dans
la dans le prolongement de notre sujet
d'ouverture l'ex-agent herman hesse le
président est affaibli sur la scène
internationale au sortir d'une fête ou
d'une semi défaite électorale appelant
ça comme on veut je crois que c'est
normal qu'on pose la question en
revanche pour une fois je n'ai pas la
même grille de lecture que ce que disait
patrick martin geniez où souvent on a
les mêmes approches mais je pense que
c'est plus une question franco française
qui se posent mais si on a un prisme
plus européen
finalement il va y avoir et d'ailleurs
c'était dit dans votre votre reportage
c'est dans les couloirs mais qu'est ce
que ça change en réalité réellement sur
les pouvoirs sur ce sur quoi on peut
influer
je suis plus dubitative pourquoi parce
que sur le régalien ça va pas changer
grand chose sachant que au niveau
européen on a l'habitude des notions de
compromis et que c'est plutôt quelque
chose qui est mise en avant sur lesquels
il faut travailler ou pour le coup la
france n'était pas très en avance de
phase parce qu'on a du mal avec cette
national et au niveau européen compromis
n'est pas égal à compromission c'est
plutôt un signe de maturité politique
est d'ailleurs bien d'autres chefs de
gouvernement ne sont pas à la tête de
majorité oui mais pour l'instant la
majorité absolue il n'a pas trouvé non
plus non mais bien sûr j'attends déjà là
en train de vous dire que c'est un
succès mais vous par rapport à la à la
séquence de l'affaiblissement
internationale du président je serais
plus mesurés parce que je pense que
c'est normal qu'on se pose la question
du point de vue de notre prisme français
mais que du point de vue européen
c'est pas ça qui est en tête des
priorités sur le régalien
c'est toujours le président qui ya un
certain nombre de pouvoirs ça changera
en revanche certainement dans la mise en
avaient fini par là mais dans la mise en
oeuvre si vous êtes dans une logique de
transposition d'un certain nombre de
directives européennes par exemple déjà
c'est très long mais là oui évidemment
s'il n'a pas la majorité pour être
capable de transposer ça peut avoir un
impact par rapport à l'union européenne
je vais reprendre explique une
expression qui est qui nous vient des
états unis quand le président réélu perd
les élections de mi-mandat on parle de
lame duck le canard boiteux est ce que
emmanuel macron est un peu un canard
boiteux depuis quelques jours la réponse
c'est tiendra en fait dans les groupes
d'opposition en fait c'est intéressant
ce que vous disiez sur le côté
on a l'habitude en europe on a
l'habitude des compromissions la
question c'est est-ce qu'en france enfin
des compromis et pas des commissions
versées bien sûr la question c'est est
ce qu'on france on sait faire ça on a un
régime présidentiel voilà depuis des
dizaines d'années et là on est supposé
avoir un système où les groupes
d'opposition en devoir discuter avec le
gouvernement
se mette d'accord voter des textes
en fait on est incapable de prédire
comment ça va se passer parce que là on
a bien vu par exemple sur la droite en
particulier disent pas de coalition mais
on votera au cas par cas on fera nos
propres propositions pareil nul c'est la
france un sou 12h10 on fera nos propres
propositions donc en fait on sait un
saut dans l'inconnu et aucun d'entre
nous ne sait je pense plaisir là tout de
suite ce qui va se passer alors jean
louis missika vous avez publié pour
terra nova une note le titre ses adieux
jupiter mais ça c'est quand même ce que
alors je sais pas si emmanuel macron l'a
totalement intégré le critère mais vous
vous pensez que c'est la leçon de ces la
leçon du scrutin ah bah oui je pense que
c'est la leçon du scrutin dans le sens
où il avait promis
une mandature très différente des
précédentes avec beaucoup plus de
dialogue beaucoup plus d'ouverture
beaucoup plus
d'horizontalité par rapport à fameuse
verticalité du pouvoir qu'on lui a
reprochées l'ordre et les français l'ont
pris au mot et lui ont dit chiche et
donc ils eurent dit ben le plus simple
pour être sûr que tu ne seras plus
jupiter bah c'est qu'on va pas de donner
une majorité absolue au parlement wallon
pub et donc c'est ça le résultat de
cette élection je veux juste aller dans
le sens de ce qui a été dit en france on
dit qu'il a perdu les élections partout
ailleurs en europe pour nous répond on
dirait qu'il a gagné les élections c'est
ça c'est un des aspects les plus
étranges de la situation justement que
nous vivons celui là quoi qu'il arrive
lundi la santé pour cent des députés
jusqu'à 30% de la députée et aïeux
ailleurs
scholl's à 28% des députés spd au
parlement allemand et
sanchez à 34 % de députées ps au
parlement espagnol donc vous voyez bien
que d'un certain point de vue on peut
dire que la situation des manuels macro
aider avec board est un petit peu plus
confortable que celle de shaw lls et
mais je vais tout à fait dans votre sens
où ils ont l'habitude de discuter enfin
regardez ça car abritant quatre
élections anticipées en quatre ans en
espagne parce que ni le pp ni le pse ne
voulait dealé avec les indépendantistes
basques et les indépendantistes catalans
quatre fois son îlot ils ont obligé les
espagnols à aller aux urnes jusqu'à ce
que de guerre lasse il
il accepte et d'ailleurs aujourd'hui
c'est quelque chose qu'on ignore mais
qui est quand même très intéressant le
parti indépendantiste basque issus de
thé a donc le mouvement terroriste
soutient la coalition
baïdu soutient la coalition de monsieur
sanchez donc on voyait bien c'est tout
le sujet c'est ça c est ce que cette
culture du dialogue et du compromis et
je voudrais aussi rappeler un tout petit
détail soit parle de 48 heures d'une
semaine et ces deux mois de discussions
pour la coalition mais oui mais oui en
une coalition ça se fait pas en une
semaine ni en une journée donc ça aussi
c'est quelque chose qui est radicalement
différent par rapport à ce qu'on connaît
sur la forme si on parle de
communication politique l'éthicien
comment vous analysez la c8 minutes de
discours je rappelle le 15 millions 500
mille téléspectateurs devant leur
télévision j'ai pas eu d'accord avec
jean louis missika mais je trouve que
cette prise de parole était tardive très
tardive je l'attendais tout de suite moi
dimanche soir je sais bien qu'il y avait
un diabète ban qui devait s'exprimer
mais on a entendu dans la bouche et
isabelle borne emmanuel macron et ça a
été un fiasco donc honnêtement j'ai
trouvé ça très tardif est complètement
conforme à la communication des manuels
macron depuis son entrée en campagne
dans la présidentielle est donc décalé
décalé pourquoi parce qu'ils finissent
sur cette idée de france unie et donc
c'est toujours son inspiration
mitterrandienne 88 il est toujours collé
à ce modèle parce qu'il nous dit il dit
aux français nous avons vécu des crises
et donc ce slogan la france unie c'est
ce qu'il avait commencé à impulser
pendant la crise la crise du coville est
là il finit là dessus et il me semble
qu'il est décalé par rapport à la
réalité de ce que l'on vit aujourd'hui
nous sommes en désaccord je partais non
non je pense qu'eux mêmes
et d'inflexion le problème c'est qu'il
était un peu à côté de la plaque il
était un peu à côté de la plaque il il
n'a pas trouvé le ton juste ni ni la
bonne ni la bonne attitude notamment il
aurait pu s'appuyer sur l'idée que par
définition une coalition ça prend
énormément de temps ils auraient pu
acheter du temps en cours de cette
intervention alors que là sont ces
équipes sont obligés de démentir le fait
qu'ils aient posé un ultimatum de 48
heures et vous voyez bien que la
question fondamentale c'est celle là
c'est il faut il faut laisser du temps
au temps a pour le coup ce serait très
bien mon retour j'attendrai les
propositions de l'opposition passait
très clair les hématomes mais ça c'était
possible ses positions à battice et pas
à l'opposition de faire des propositions
d'action on démarre enfin oui alors
objectivement quand on réécoute c'est ce
que le président dit juste pour rebondir
je trouve que c'est très intéressant
parce que sur la partie jupitérienne
juste un mot c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
ce qu'il joue c'est qu'en fait on avait
le pouvoir de l'exécutif et aujourd'hui
on voit la bascule vers à nouveau un
pouvoir du législatif bon c'est ça qui
se joue en réalité c'est nous bascule au
fur et à mesure où jusqu'à présent dans
le premier la première mandature vous
aviez vraiment un exécutif extrêmement
fort et là vous allez avec d'ailleurs on
le regrettait pardon nous interrompons
le regrettait souvent dix ans qu'on
avait des députés godillots pour prendre
une vieille expression playmobil pour en
prendre une plus jeune donc on peut dire
c'est mais c'est bien ça serait
équilibre oui alors ça serait équilibre
avec évidemment la capacité du compromis
on en a parlé mais également maintenant
c'est au pied du mur c'est à dire qu'on
va voir tous ces députés nouvellement
élus il faut qu'il soit aussi en mesure
d'être responsables pour être à la
hauteur de la confiance qui leur a été
confié et on a vu au début toutes les
questions qu'il y avait autour de ces
nouveaux députés la reine qui changeait
de vie et qui devenait député la chose
publique est une chose où il y a un coût
d'entrée aussi c'est à dire que il y a
des codes il ya des modes de pratiques
de réflexion ce sont des compétences
différentes aussi qui sont requises et
donc il faut très vite être au travail
parce que la situation de la de la
france le nécessite avec peut-être juste
un petit mot évidemment je trouve que
sur l'allocution du président
pour une fois une allocution qui était
quand même concise selda souligné donc
ça veut dire aussi peut-être quelque
chose dans une prise de parole
également une j'ai trouvé que c'était
quand même cohérent et avec
une prise de parole qui était assez
réaliste pourquoi on n'en a pas parlé
mais il commence très vite mais ça parle
le couplet sur la légitimité
présidentielle
sur les 26 millions d'abstentionnistes
et ça c'est quand même un sujet c'est
une évidence mais c'est une évidence
mais par personne il n'est pas
nom par nom parle aujourd'hui est le
vrai sujet que l'on a aussi mais qui
s'adresse à toutes les forces politiques
c'est ce qui devrait nous rassembler en
priorité c'est comment fait-on pour que
ça n'arrive pas à nouveau parce que
arrivé à nouveau c'est significatif
d'une démocratie qui est vraiment en
état de maladie forte vous dites les
députés doivent être conscients de la
responsabilité qui leur a été confiée
par les électeurs c'est vrai mais il ya
beaucoup aussi de députés qui ont été
élues justement sur cette opposition à
emmanuel macron qui disent on a été élu
parce que clairement on s'est opposé ont
été réélus d'ailleurs parce qu'on a on
s'est opposé donc ils auront peut-être
alors peut-être que je me trompe
peut-être que je suis pessimiste mais
j'ai l'impression qu'il y en a certains
qui vont avoir la tentation de s'opposer
par principe d'accord et la notation
respecter effectivement le contrat passé
avec le lecteur suit je sais que vous
avez un petit tigre indique
juste pour clore notre discussion en
tout cas ce chapitre là je pense qu'on
est complètement à côté de la plaque
quand on diagnostique et on fait le
bilan des intentions des électeurs je
crois que il n'y a pas de sens politique
de dire ah le présidentialisme c'est
vraiment fini on veut retourner vers
plus de parlementarisme je ne crois pas
thomas je crois qu'il ya une société qui
est fracturée qui a décidé de voter et
de m adam la chine dans cette chambre 90
députés du rassemblement national qui a
décidé de voter en fonction de ses
affinités quand on votait puisqu'il y en
a sur deux qui n'a pas voté et surtout
contre emmanuel macron et je crois que
ça s'est vraiment fondamental pour
comprendre ce qui s'est passé et non pas
alors on adorerait que tout le monde ait
un sens politique très aiguisé me
remettre plus de débats et de compromis
dans la décision publique je ne crois
pas mais moi je crois à l'intelligence
c'est
d'accord t'es gentille mais c'est un
débat qu'on pourra voir sur ce plateau
parce qu'il est passionnant mais une
prochaine fois parce que voudrait qu'on
propose alexandre touzard de nous
rejoindre bonsoir enfin pour donc après
ce discours présidentiel hier hier soir
comment ont réagi les les groupes
d'opposition à l'assemblée nationale
mais on va commencer par le premier
groupe d'opposition à l'assemblée le
groupe du rassemblement national avec
marine le pen qui est désormais
président de ce groupe et hier soir elle
a publié un communiqué qui est très
claire sur l'allocution du président de
la république elle le dit les 89 députés
du raid url n'entreront jamais dans une
collation dans une coalition macro nice
pour mettre en oeuvre des orientations
qu'ils entendent combattre il réaffirme
toutefois leur intention d'examiner les
textes à la lumière de l'intérêt des
français et de la france à gauche
maintenant jean luc mélenchon qui n'est
plus député mais dont l'apport le compte
forcément au sein de la france insoumise
et de la nouvelle union populaire
écologiques et sociales et bien jean luc
mélenchon il souhaite d'abord que la
chef du gouvernement la première
ministre elisabeth board elles
obtiennent le vote de confiance de la
nouvelle assemblée nationale élue avant
de pouvoir discuter les premiers textes
ecoutez jean luc mélenchon
inutile de contourner la réalité madame
la première ministre comme dans toutes
les démocraties du monde doit se
présenter devant l'assemblée nationale
et sollicité sa confiance si elle n'a
pas cette confiance elle doit s'en aller
et si elle a cette confiance elle
présentera des textes et alors sur la
base des textes chacun fera comme il l'a
fait dans le passé les propositions
qu'il estime nécessaires et qui sont
conformes à l'intérêt général
voilà pour la méthode qui est souhaitée
par jean luc mélenchon alors au sein de
cette nuit baisse il ya également les
socialistes qu'on pourrait penser à
peut-être plus enclins à travailler avec
emmanuel macron sur certaines réformes
on va regarder la réaction du nouveau
président du groupe socialiste à
l'assemblée boris vallot lui il choisi
de renvoyer la balle dans le camp
d'emmanuel macro nous lui posons la
question à quelques ont fourni est il
prêt hui nous avons des propositions à
faire sur le pouvoir d'achat qui est la
première des urgences est il prêt elle
est considérée et sinon le travail se
fera au parlement plutôt que
vernon hier le président a évoqué la
possibilité d'un groupe de coalition
main tendue aux ou pdf qui possède 61
députés qui pourraient apporter
évidemment cette majorité à emmanuel
macron alors comment eux ont-ils réagi
fabien pas très bien thomas les députés
les républicains des républicains sont
fermement opposés à une coalition de
gouvernement avec emmanuel macron c'est
hors de question il ne croit pas non
plus à cette idée de dépassement
politique qui a été défendu une nouvelle
fois hier soir par emmanuel macron on va
écouter aurélien pradié réélu député du
lot et secrétaire général du parti des
républicains le dépassement politique je
dis à nos auditeurs qui peut être doit
se dire c'est qu'à même bienne
dépassement politique ça évite les
chamailleries politiques mais quand vous
éviter le débat politique sur le fond
quand vous tenter d'effacer les
conditions vous en venez à n'avoir au
final que les extrêmes qui incarne
quelque chose et cela c'est la
responsabilité politique majeur des
manuels matheron l est républicain qui
veulent donc se positionner en fonction
de chaque projet de loi a finalement
l'opposition elle ne laisse qu'une seule
solution pour emmanuel macron c'est
aller chercher une majorité texte par
texte merci alexandre rester là parce
que depuis tout à l'heure je me dis
quand même c'est
vous n'aurez pas le temps de changer de
costume donc je vous accepte en gris et
bleu allez on redevient sérieux ça va
belouizad sur les 61 députés aient l'air
qui ont sauvé leur siège c'est déjà ça
peut-être le point de départ ils ont
sauvé leur ciel m descons cattin oui oui
il ya des conquêtes je sais bien mais
ils suivent un peu quand même deux comme
des survivants d'après ce que j'ai
compris combien son maquereau compatible
c'est la grande phrase de la semaine
c'est très compliqué à dire parce que
ceux qui sont revenus finalement sont
des gens qui avaient pour la plupart un
député un candidat ma chronique face à
eux ils le disent eux mêmes c'est leur
expression ils se sont arrachés des
flammes de l'enfer ils sont ils ont
sillonné leur dire qu ils les ont
labourer et ils sont revenus donc même
ceux qui éventuellement aurait pu être
peut-être macron compatible à certains
égards il y en a quelques-uns ils sont
pas très nombreux mais il y en a
quelques-uns là ils n'ont pas non plus
envie de se lancer dans une coalition
voyait lits sont plutôt en mode on va
voter texte par texte et on verra la
suite parce qu'en plus ils se disent
maintenant il n'est pas réélu fin l'idée
c'est fini dans cinq ans donc là bas on
retrouve le canard boiteux dont je
parlais tout à l'heure il est fini dans
cinq ans qu à quoi ça sert de le
soutenir maintenant en revanche y en a
un qui pourrait soutenir et que vous
soutenez si je ne me trompe à
l'extérieur on s'était douar philippe et
ce qui est à la manoeuvre en ce moment
pour essayer de voile a raccroché des
peut-être des divers droite ou des who
dlr au camp de la majorité vous doutez
que je ne peux pas parler au nom
d'edouard philippe en revanche qu'on
peut regarder avec intérêt c'est que la
première des choses quand vous cherchez
à élargir votre majorité c'est que déjà
il faut consolider la sienne
donc c'est très important aussi on voit
bien que le la démarche de françois
bayroux d'edouard philippe d'essayer de
deux de tirer vers l'ouverture
j'entendais sur votre antenne la porte
parole de d'horizons agnès firmin le
bodo qui était questionné sur ces sujets
des aides vous une cheville ouvrière il
y a en tout cas un passage pour ceux qui
ont des valeurs de droits parce qu'
edouard philippe assume comme vous le
savez évidemment c'est la première chose
qu'il avait dit quand il est arrivé sur
le perron de l'elysée c'est un homme de
droite avec des valeurs de droite et
donc il y as forcément des passerelles
qui peuvent se faire avec une une
ouverture pour dans le camp des
républicains
essayez d'aller trouver alain je vous
rejoins dans l'idéal une coalition mais
aujourd'hui en tout cas au début du
chemin c'est bien difficile donc ce qui
semble préhensibles en tout cas c'est
peut-être majorité texte par texte mais
vous savez c'est important vous vous
savez c'est comme une négociation
contractuelle c'est là où quelque part
il faut prendre du recul quand chacun
vient en disant voilà mon programme le
président sait ce qu'il y a il a caprins
de mon programme et on sera d'accord
c'est pas ça une négociation mais c'est
un peu ce qu emmanuel macron avait fait
hier soir dans son discours en rappelant
que dans la ddcs l'art telle
responsabilité dans la partie clarté il
déroule son programme oui mais ce qui
compte au bout d'un moment et c'est
comme ça que ça des quand il parle pas
des autres images à exactement et c'est
comme ça que ça des comptes c'est que
vous allez trouver le fil rouge la
colonne vertébrale sur laquelle vous
pouvez trouver un point d'accord et
après chaque partie doit faire des pas
l'un vers l'autre est là pour une négo
c'est de voir philippe ii de former une
coalition parce que c'était sa
proposition a été retoqué par le
président et puis aussi retoqué
ce navire qui n'est pas y avait aussi
l'idée de l'envoyer justement edouard
philippe et françois bayrou essayer de
voir quelles alliances pouvait être
signée piqué l'union on pouvait on
pouvait former finalement emmanuel
macron là aussi laissé de côté non mais
vous avez vous avez vraiment envie de
donner non plus plus de responsables
vous avez je ne dis pas ça mais vous
avez plus généralement le ministre
d'état chargé des relations avec le
parlement alors là pour le coup olivier
ferrand
c il a du travail d'isabelle bande aussi
son téléphone chauffe un petit peu je
crois alors il ya une un extrait de la
déclaration de du président de la
république hier soir que je voudrais
qu'on réécoute parce que moi je ne suis
pas très doué en maths mais j'avais fait
mes calculs j'avais chiffres 44 en tête
245 députés
de la majorité +44 ça faisait 2 189 hier
le président a dit autre chose
aucune force politique ne peut
aujourd'hui faire les lois seul il a
manqué une trentaine de députés sur 577
et la majorité présidentielle est en
effet relative ça veut dire quoi jean
louis missika je ne peux pas croire
qu'il se soit trompé dire c'est qu'ils
ont déjà convaincu déjà il ya ce qu'on
appelle les
ensembles dissidents moi je sais pas
combien ils sont vous de le savoir en
trois ou quatre
qui se sont présentés contre des
candidats comme par exemple manuel valls
e pour les français de l'étranger et
qu'ils ont et qu'ils ont gagné donc ceux
là vont entrer au bercail vous avez il
vous a pas échappé que un groupe ultra
marins a été constitué qui s'est déclaré
non upps alors que certains de ses
candidats avaient été des candidats
soutenus par la nouvelle union populaire
et ce groupe on ne sait pas exactement
quelle taille il aura m'enfin c'est
entre 18 et 24 donc vous voyez bien que
il y à des centres il ya des divers
gauche et des divers droite et donc je
ne sais pas où en sont les ou en sont
les discussions avec tous ces gens là
mais vous savez moi j'ai travaillé avec
michel rocard à l'époque où il était
premier ministre et je me souviens très
bien du du regretté guy carcassonne qui
était son membre de cabinet en charge
des relations avec le parlement et ses
majorités à géométrie variable et il
fallait les constitué à chaque fois mais
il y a un certain nombre de députés qui
vraisemblablement ont déjà acté le fait
qu' il soutiendrait d'une façon ou d'une
autre le pouvoir je voudrais juste
insister sur un point par rapport à
cette solution de voter des lois au cas
par cas
c'est le risque de l'immobilisme sur les
sujets difficiles parce qu'en réalité on
voit bien qu'il sera sans doute facile
en tout cas possible de trouver une
majorité au parlement sur le pouvoir
d'achat
mais sur des sujets comme les retraites
ça risque d'être beaucoup plus difficile
est donc le principal risque pour moi de
cette situation c'est le fait qu'aucune
des réformes structurelles promises dans
le le programme des manuels macron ne
soient effectivement mises en oeuvre et
que en réalité on aille de loi facile
aux lois facile mais pourtant sur les
retraites on pourrait imaginer les
députés allaient revoter au moins cette
fois oui après les députés alors ils
sont aussi divisés là dessus vous savez
bien il ya une frange de députés un peu
plus sociaux comme on dit qui disent 65
ans c'est dur alors même que c'était
dans le programme de
donc et puis mais même sur le pouvoir
d'achat je ne sais même pas s'ils vont
pouvoir voter conforme sais même pas si
c'est une loi qui va être facile à faire
passer non
c'est pas évident ce sera le premier
test oui voilà ce serait profitable et
encore ça vous avez raison c'est plus
facile que des réformes beaucoup plus
clémente mais en tout cas c'est
impossible de prévoir comment ils vont
faire parce qu'en plus ils ont d'autres
intérêts savaient ils ont leurs intérêts
personnels chaque député dans sa
circonscription de sa situation est ce
que c'est une circo rural est ce que
c'est une circo urbaine
est-ce que c'est plutôt une sociologie
populaire ou plutôt plus riches ensuite
il ya les problématiques 2027 avec les
éventuels candidats qui ont envie que
les groupes parlementaires ne soit pas
forcément se désolidarise des manuels
macron en vue en 2027 de ne pas assumer
un bilan etc
on dit on dit qu'on dit que là les
institutions désagréable clique sont
très souples et que l'on peut basculer
du présidentialisme au parlementarisme
de façon quand même assez simple et
c'est une des grandes forces de la
constitution de la vème république
sauf que ça n'est pas vraiment une
constitution parlementaire est la grande
différence justement c'est cette
élection présidentielle et donc les
stratégies des candidats pour l'élection
présidentielle qui peuvent contrecarrer
les alliances ou les compromis ou les
dispositions ça peut valoir cyril qui
même si les a tuées les discussions en
fait oui alors vous allez allez allez
viol est ce que est ce que les électeurs
le supportons
je pense qu'on est vraiment passé il y a
quelque chose que l'on doit maintenant
intégré et ça n'a que trop tardé sait
qu'on est rentré d'engins une autre
relation à la politique si on part du
principe ce que vous disiez laetitia et
j'y souscris à c'est que c'est un vote
qui montre les fractures de la société
est quelque part une remontée finalement
de ce qu'on a connu pendant la période d
gilet jaune c'est ça à droite comme à
gauche à ce moment là ça veut dire que
il faut vraiment être en accord avec la
tente des électeurs et les électeurs ne
supporteront plus que même les députés
qui l'ont élu viennent à faire passer
leurs problématiques
j'allais dire géostratégique et euros
stratégiques ou parlement arrow
stratégique face alors à l'intérêt
général il n'ya le pays n'est pas en en
crise nécessitant une union nationale
c'est très clair l'union nationale c'est
c'est un une autre thématique mais en
revanche on est
ex explosé finalement de multi fracture
et il faut prendre ça en compte
aujourd'hui j'aimerais qu'on regarde un
sondage au dos que ça pour le figaro
sondages publiés sortie en cette fin
d'après midi 64% des français estiment
que c'est une bonne chose qu'il n'y ait
pas de majorité absolue à l'assemblée
nationale premiers chiffres et puis un
deuxième 57% des personnes interrogées
disent qu emmanuel macron alors le terme
exact c'est n'a pas ou plus d'autre
solution que de changer de premier
ministre jean louis missika vous seriez
conseillé d' emmanuel macron voulu
duriez de garder les avait deux bornes
wii lancée par ouï de la garde et oui
clairement bah parce que le changement
de premier ministre ne peut être que le
résultat
de la fin de la négociation avec les
différentes forces politiques si jamais
une coalition arrivée à se constituèrent
je ne sais pas ni comment ni pourquoi
et peut-être que dans le dans le deal
dans la négociation un nouveau premier
ministre pourrait pourrait émerger mais
aujourd'hui
changer de premier ministre s'est brûlé
une cartouche dont ils risquent d'avoir
besoin d'ici deux ou trois mois donc si
vous voulez mon sentiment c'est que
elisabeth bornes alors on dit elle n'est
pas faite c'est une technocrate et donc
elle n'a pas le sens politique
nécessaire mais moi je sais qu'elle peut
nous surprendre on l'a souvent sous les
élever dans sa carrière et c'est vous
pensez c'est moins pire qu edouard
philippe excusez moi parce qu' edouard
philippe il s'était d'ailleurs lui-même
l'a dit je suis un irritant pour pour
les élus a l'air et donc si vous prenez
un politique politique lequel vous allez
prendre c'est extrêmement compliqué oui
j'en ai
proposé si on l'a bien compris mais
peut-être qu'elle isabelle borne
justement à cause de cette espèce de
neutralité que dégage une technocrate et
mieux en mieux à même de mener cette
négociation mais il faudrait que et
c'est là où on revient à jupiter qui n'a
pas complètement disparu il faudrait que
emmanuel macron lui donne un mandat
clair voilà tu essaies face et que ce
soit elle qui mène la négociation pour
le moment on n'en est pas là en tout cas
c'est elle n'était pas à la table avec
emmanuel macron quand il a reçu les
chefs de partis on va maintenant ouvrir
un chapitre consacré au rassemblement
national comment réagit comment réagira
le rassemblement national dans les
prochaines semaines dans les prochains
mois des indices laetitia hier sous
l'oeil des caméras à l'assemblée des
images quelques mots nous nous indique
le rôle que marine le pen entend jouer
nous on les a vu ces images d'arrivée
massive des 89 députés alors quand on
regarde vraiment au premier degré on les
voit tous très bien habillé les hommes
portant cravate et les femmes avec des
tenues combat parce que consigne leur
avaient été données effectivement de
porter des tenues correctes c'est marine
le pen qui s'en est chargé et donc on au
delà de cette question des apparences on
comprend le message qui est envoyé aux
français marine le pen sera la
principale opposante à emmanuel macron
et surtout ce parti sera enfin
normalisée je vous propose d'écouter ce
qu'a dit et dans son point presse très
court mais très clair jordan bardella le
patron du rassemblement national
l'opposition pour nous n'est pas une fin
en soi mais un moyen de protéger les
français de préparer l'accession
responsabilités et d'épargné notre pays
à notre pays la liquidation qu emmanuel
macron s'empresse d'achever avant le
terme de son mandat une étape
supplémentaire dans notre accession aux
responsabilités est désormais accomplie
j'appelle donc tous les français d'où
qu'ils viennent quelle qu'ait été leur
choix politiques passées à s'engager à
s'impliquer dans la vie politique à
rejoindre le rassemblement national à
nous rejoindre et à préparer à nos côtés
la grande alternance dont notre pays a
besoin
alors cette arrivée massive un député du
rassemblement national à l'assemblée
marque vraiment un tournant il me semble
dans l'histoire de notre pays de la vème
république parce que dans la bouche et
jordan bardella comme de marine le pen
c'est le mot républicain qui revient le
plus souvent ils veulent absolument être
considéré comme un parti républicain et
donc être inclus dans ce système qui
l'ont owni pendant des années c'était
quand même le fonds de commerce du front
national puis du rassemblement national
de pointer ce système qui était injuste
et qui ne comprenait pas le peuple
désormais il faudra compter nous
distille avec le rassemblement national
avec l'extrême droite pour gouverner ou
en tout cas pour avoir à faire avec les
décideurs et les affaires politiques du
pays marine le pen qui je la cite un qui
parle d'une opposition républicaine mais
intransigeante la fin du processus on
l'a déjà évoqué ici fin des processus de
dédiabolisation totalement cer n va
prendre parti à la marche politique de
la france comme aux en italie comme dans
d'autres pays en allemagne aussi où
l'extrême droite est là et fait partie
de la coalition de gouvernement mais ce
qui a retenu mon attention daumas c'est
surtout le verbatim qui l accompagne la
fin de ce processus de dédiabolisation
marine le pen affirment qu'ils voteront
dans l'intérêt on l'a entendu dans la
chronique d'alexandre tout à l'heure
dans l'intérêt des français et pour la
france alors ce long voile à la place
que l'on prend pour pour analyser ces
déclarations on se dit soit ce sont des
des allégations populistes ou soit il y
a quand même dans l'arrivée encore une
fois c'est 90 députés 89 89 un signal
dans le rapport qu'ils ont au peuple
pourquoi parce qu'un quart de ses
députés sont soient ouvriers soient
employés soient issus de professions
intermédiaires alors les médias se sont
un peu comme ça passionné pour le cas de
rachel kéké de la nu cette femme qui
avait été engagé dans le combat syndical
dans les bisses de des batignolles me
semble-t-il cette femme de chambre eh
bien écoutez dans les rangs du
rassemblement national il ya aussi une
chef d'equipe de nettoyage il ya une
assistante sociale et des ouvriers et
c'est bien la représentativité de ce
groupe qui marque me semble-t-il et qui
montre que la politique peut-être vous
le disais tout à l'heure à l'ecoute est
représentative encore une fois des
français et de sept couches populaires
qui a complètement déserté les partis
traditionnels on y reviendra sur la
sociologie de l'assemblée j'espère qu'on
aura le temps alex et germond et lille
pas de couloirs secrets entre entre le
palais bourbon et l'elysée mais pour
marine le pen ce qu'on voit bien là
naître dès les premiers jours c'est que
l'assemblée c'est un marchepied c'est
clair c'est clair c'est assumer
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui fait pour tous
ceux qui combattent les valeurs du
rassemblement national que la vigilance
doit être très grande avec quand même
une
réelle difficulté pour marine le pen
c'est qu'elle est à la tête de
primo-accédants et donc il faut aussi
que l arrive allez allez former pour
être efficace très rapidement qu'il n'y
ait pas de débordements donc je pense
que ce sera intéressant de voir de
quelle façon cette formation accélérée
va va se faire parce que c'est mon jour
gros je note également
que pendant des années vous le disiez
effectivement ce système ces
institutions ont été très critiqués mise
au ban par le rn parce que l ce système
ne leur permettaient pas d'accéder au
pouvoir on voit bien que même sans
proportionnelle et je me dis pas qu'il
n'en faut pas un mais même sans
proportionnelle ils ont été capables de
faire ce score qui est un score hors
norme et qui était totalement inattendu
et non produit par les institutions
marine le pen qui demande pour son parti
premier parti d'opposition la prégnance
de la commission des finances gérard
larcher qui était
interrogé dans les colonnes du parisien
aujourd'hui en france hier dit ceci il
ya un règlement l'assemblée nationale
qui dit que le président de la
commission des finances doit être issu
de l'opposition je constate que la rien
le premier groupe d'opposition donc
elle devrait lui lui revenir on peut
peut-être jean-louis rappeler comment ça
se passe c'est un vote c'est un vote
alors à priori les députés du premier
groupe ne prenne pas papa mais bon on
verra bien c'est 900 mhz et laissé 7 900
mêlée et surtout on a peut-être un peu
de mal à imaginer les députés de la
nuque ou même de l air on ne sait pas
mais bon député danube voter pour marine
le pen ou pour un candidat ou une
candidate poussé par le et rennes qui
vivent absolument à bas qu'est ce qui va
se passer ça c'est difficile de répondre
à cette question vraiment parce que on
ne sait pas si les élus ensemble vont
décider de participer au vote ce qui
serait une entorse à la tradition ou pas
mais pas aux règlements ses sa annonce
faite membre à d'autres oui ce n'est
qu'une tradition c'est elle qui dit si
ça ce n'est qu'une tradition que le que
le groupe majoritaire ne participent pas
au vote faut aider mais vous voyez
pardon parisien est inscrit dans les
dents dans le règlement de l'assemblée
c'est qu'effectivement le siège revient
à un élu de l'opposition sans préciser
quelle opposition c'est à dire que si
jamais l air est ensemble se mettre
d'accord pour que ce soit un élu a l'air
ce sera un élu a l'air quant à la quant
à la nuque soutenu baisse je sais pas ce
qu'il faut et l'inusable académie
française a dit nul voilà tu viens pas
pour nous chacun fait comme il veut oui
mais
la question est de savoir comment ils
vont s'entendre entre les trois groupes
puisque vous avez vu que je crois que
c'est le ps qui a proposé une présidence
tournante pour les trois les quatre
force les quatre forces concernées
l'intergroupe
je n'ai pas dit que je peux parler de
groupe je dis simplement le ps a proposé
qu' il y ait une présidence tournante
entre les quatre groupes composant la
composant la nuque et bien évidemment
les élus d'ensemble vont se retrouver en
position d'arbitré mais sinon
logiquement soit on regarde quel est le
l'alliance la plus importante et la
nuque et devant le rn soit on regarde le
groupe le plus important et le rn et
devant la france un cyclisme et devant
la nuque le rn et devant la ford a subi
on a aussi perd un peu mais ils ont tout
changé de nom récemment
devenu un peu sérieux vous évoquez
laetitia la sociologie de la nouvelle
assemblée quelques chiffres l'âge moyen
ses 48 ans et demi
il ya seulement soit 37 3% de femmes
c'est moins que dans la précédente
assemblée ça malheureusement recul et
effectivement si on regarde le profil on
va dire socioprofessionnelle de des
nouveaux députés cadres et professions
intellectuelles supérieures c'est encore
très majoritaire 58% au traité ans pour
cent sans activité 8% profession
d'intermédiaire
8% les artisans commerçants chefs
d'entreprise 6% employés 4 et
agriculteurs presque 2% et ouvriers 1%
donc on est encore dans l'ultra ultra
minoritaire il ya il ya 300 deux
nouveaux députés avec sia germond vous
l'avais un peu évoquée ils vont devoir
apprendre le métier mais c'est quand
même une bonne nouvelle aussi c'est à
une sorte de nouveau de nouveau souffle
oui non sur le fond c'est une c'est une
bonne nouvelle bien sûr pour qui une
représentativité qui ressemble plus à
l'aspiration tout simplement du corps
électoral pour essayer justement de
rassembler ses fractures de reconsolider
les choses la seule chose c'est que ça
intervient à un moment tout particulier
de l'histoire parlementaire de notre
pays et que donc ce pur pour ces
nouveaux accédants pour ces nouveaux
députés je pense que la tâche n'est pas
facile parce que on est à un moment où
vous avez des décors dont des groupes
qui se constitue et qui vont devoir très
vite reprendre le le train le train en
marche c'est ça qui est difficile c'est
que vous n'êtes pas dans une logique qui
est cadré ou c'est une alternance facile
où il n'y a pas de risque derrière parce
qu'il ya quand même on est il faut
faut-il le rappeler on est quand même
dans un contexte économique qui étaient
treize inattendue il ya six mois dans un
contexte d'inflation vous allez avoir
une remontée des taux vous allez avoir
également la partie géopolitique ou
évidemment depuis trois quatre mois
c'est le quotidien mais c'est loin
d'être fini donc tout ça se fait sur un
fond où il y aura des discussions et des
décisions à prendre qui sont
particulièrement structurant pour notre
pays il faut pas oublier le taux
d'abstention oui c'est à dire que
on a 40
7% et les électeurs qui se sont rendus
aux urnes 70% d'abstention chez les
jeunes 70% c'est une véritable crise
démocratique que nous vivons et 7
nous faisons partie des dettes du cercle
des initiés donc nous sommes dans une
situation où nous discutons dans le
détail de ce qui va se passer au
parlement etc enfin il faut pas oublier
cette masse de gens qui se
désintéressent complètement de la
politique et qui ne se et qui ne se
préoccupe pas de du fonctionnement
démocratique des institutions et ça
c'est vraiment un enjeu pour les partis
politiques
ça devrait être un enjeu collectif et
qui puisse réunir évidemment tout le
monde merci beaucoup d'avoir participé à
ce débat merci tous jean louis missika
j'appelle le titre de votre livre le
business de la haine internet la
démocratie et les réseaux sociaux qu
écrivait quand et verdier est publié aux
éditions calmann lévy